revista de prensa con Marta Moya Buenos
días Marta para ustedes Hola Ángela
feliz viernes Igualmente para usted
Marta vamos a abrir esta sección con el
medio ruso musky Times ayer publicó un
reportaje en el que destaca al
controvertido líder del grupo Wagner
Jenny que además está habitualmente en
nuestros titulares pero dice que no
siempre estuvo a favor de las armas
quisiéramos saber qué hay detrás de esa
historia pues esto yo creo que te va a
sorprender Angela al igual que a
nuestros televidentes porque
los últimos tiempos pues lo conocemos no
por liderar el grupo Wagner por liderar
la toma de bahamut También estuvo en la
cárcel 9 años por robo declaró o afirmó
haber interferido en las elecciones
presidenciales de Estados Unidos en el
año 2020 también está acusado
actualmente de crímenes de guerra en
Ucrania este medio independiente ruso
Times nos da ahora datos curiosos sobre
el pasado de pregogen el primero es que
tenía o es conocido como de Putin porque
regentaba una cadena de restaurantes en
San Petersburgo y además Bueno pues
ofrecía servicios de catering al
presidente ruso pero aquí el dato más
curioso es que fue hace 20 años
ilustrador de cuentos infantiles Ángela
este medio ha tenido acceso a una novela
llamada indra guzik que escribió
pregojin junto a sus hijos polina y
Pavel un libro que del que solo se
imprimieron 2000 copias sí que se
rumorea que solo se distribuyó a amigos
y socios comerciales de la actual líder
del grupo Wagner este libro es la única
prueba gráfica de las artes ilustradas
de el líder de Wagner y todos los
dibujos en esta novela de 90 páginas se
atribuyen a jeffjan y pregojin el libro
está ambientado en una tierra de gente
pequeña y cuenta la historia de un niño
de indra Gucci como se llama el nombre
del protagonista que vive entre humanos
si sigue a ese personaje principal desde
que se cae en la lámpara de un teatro
hasta que intenta llegar a su casa un
dato bien curioso y que nunca le
habríamos atribuido a un personaje tan
polémico en los últimos tiempos citado
un experto político por este medio por
el Moscú Times llamado constanting dice
un poco que prego Gina ha evolucionado
con el espíritu de Rusia textualmente
dice es como un espejo de los tiempos
mientras ser bueno estaba de moda
pregojin era bueno ilustraba libros
infantiles cuándo llegó el momento del
mal se convirtió en el malvado además
destaca el mosqui Times que sus hijos
han seguido un poco la senda de su padre
su hijo Pavel de 27 años actualmente ha
combatido con Wagner tanto en Siria como
en el este de Ucrania y su hija polina
regenta en estos momentos un lujoso
complejo hotelero en la ciudad de San
Petersburgo pero sabe Marta que me
entristece un poco escuchar esta noticia
porque pues porque es una Clara muestra
de que y otros mundos posibles no y en
otras realidades y en otros contextos
pues nuestra vida puede tomar rumbos
inesperados Así que lógicamente pues son
cambios simplemente y y cuesta imaginar
es la humanidad de los combatientes que
hay en el frente pero gracias porque
porque lo logró usted Esta mañana verdad
vamos a cambiar de tema este viernes la
portada de la revista Time nos trae un
anuncio que es alarmante pero que
también es muy importante acerca de la
Inteligencia artificial Vamos a ponernos
más graves en estos artículos así es Y
si hablábamos de Cómo le cambio la vida
pregogen también vamos a hablar ahora de
cómo nos puede cambiar a nosotros la
vida con la Inteligencia artificial
hemos destacado la portada de la revista
Time de este mes de junio una portada
muy gráfica y concisa que titula el fin
de la humanidad como de Real es el
riesgo y destaca la a y la i esas dos
siglas de la Inteligencia artificial en
el interior de sus páginas la revista
Time ya nos amplía un poco esta
información con un artículo que titula
Inteligencia artificial no es una
carrera armamentística y el artículo
empieza así textualmente la ventana de
lo que la Inteligencia artificial no
puede hacer parece contraerse semana
tras semana las máquinas ahora pueden
escribir prosa elegante generar códigos
aprobar exámenes inventarse arte y
predecir el comportamiento de las
proteínas es un artículo con una visión
muy occidentalista pero también bien
realista primero dice que los expertos
tienen miedo una encuesta o más de 550
investigadores de la Inteligencia
artificial dice la mitad de ellos piensa
que el desarrollo desenfrenado de este
tipo de inteligencia generativa puede
generar al menos el 10% de posibilidades
de que todo acabe extremadamente mal y
con todo extremadamente mal nos
referimos a la extinción humana el
argumento es que el proceso o el
progreso de la Inteligencia artificial
nos puede llevar a la creación de
personas artificialmente sobrehumanas en
el plano de la inteligencia
y que pueden entrar en conflicto con los
intereses de la humanidad hacen un símil
muy concreto que dice que si una especie
O sea que la Inteligencia artificial es
una especie que para el Homo Sapiens es
lo que para el Homo sapien serían los
chimpancés otros investigadores dicen
que les preocupa que los investigadores
occidentales no corran a favor de la
Inteligencia artificial y que esto se
pueda quedar en manos de investigadores
por ejemplo chinos también da este
argumento con un símil que dice que si
una multitud de personas está sobre una
placa de hielo muy fina Si todos corren
esa placa de hielo se romperá Y si todos
caminan de manera más pausada es
probablemente que crucen y destaca este
artículo ya por finalizar una cita que
dice la mejor acción individual podría
ser moverse despacio y con cautela y
colectivamente No deberíamos permitir
que la gente se deshaga del mundo en una
perversa carrera hacia la destrucción
Especialmente cuando apenas se han
desarrollado Rutas para coordinar
nuestro a mí lo que me cuestiona mucho
es este tema que casi se ha vuelto un
tema obligado y semanal en Francia 24 de
cómo hemos desarrollado nuestros
procesos de pensamiento a tal nivel que
lo que buscamos es ya dejar de pensar no
hacernos obsoletos a nosotros mismos
Sí demasiado pero bueno Marta vamos a
hacer el cierre con un artículo muy
interesante que tiene de economista
Lástima que no haya más tiempo El rapero
Súper Estrella Bad Bunny es un buen
negocio cuéntenos sobre esto Ese es el
titular de día economist que
personalizan este cantante
puertorriqueño el auge de la cultura en
habla hispana las cuatro canciones más
escuchadas en Spotify en el mes de mayo
están escritas en español en noviembre
Bad Bunny se consolidó como el artista
más escuchado en Spotify por tercer año
consecutivo en YouTube El mexicano peso
pluma ya incluso ha superado a Bad Bunny
la música latina generó en Estados
Unidos el año pasado más de mil millones
de dólares en ingresos una tendencia que
no solo se queda en el plano musical
Ángela sino que también trasciende a
plataformas como Netflix las causas de
todo esto dice the economic son gran
parte de la facilidad de acceso a
internet en América Latina hay más de
500 millones de usuarios con teléfonos
móviles y en países como Argentina
Brasil Colombia o México la gente pasa
más de tres horas y media al día en
redes sociales y por otra parte el éxito
del auge de la cultura hispana en bueno
en la cultura en la música en la
televisión se da también por las
colaboraciones entre artistas de
diferentes países destacamos a despacito
de Luis Fonsi a los éxitos de Rosalía
con rauw Alejandro o con Bad Bunny a
Carol a Becky G perdón con peso pluma o
Face o incluso a bizarrap con Shakira no
que ha hecho un poco su marca personal
de estas colaboraciones Estados Unidos
juega un papel importante en todo esto
por el auge demográfico de la población
hispana en el territorio con más del 50%
de su población siendo hispana no y dice
que todo esto también es el resultado
creciente de la influencia
hispanohablante que es más útil Y es que
también el reggaeton penetra en ritmos
puramente anglosajones como las
canciones de Ed sheeran dua lipa o
incluso Drake pues mire Marta tengo
muchas opiniones pero no se las voy a
dar porque ya nos quedamos sin tiempo
más bien lo dejamos para nuestra propia
reflexión y la de nuestros televidentes
Muchas gracias gracias